but you notice like everybody i think
that everybody's going to be moving out
of
cities because people you see this thing
people don't want to go back to work
people are not not at all wait the
people that are working
are like i don't want to go back to the
office that's what i'm saying there are
also other people that are like i don't
want to go back to work but
what's weird about that is people forget
it's like
they act like we haven't tried this
before like silicon valley back in the
day
when it you know it's expensive out
there when they were like in their
uprise
people like facebook and google and
we're like hey we got an idea how about
you guys work from home like they've
tried this before
like why don't you guys work for home so
you're not finding place close we'll
just work for home
we'll get together like once every two
weeks and everyone's like yeah that's
great we have kids
that sounds ideal after a year they
looked at the productivity and it went
freaking it started off popping and then
they just got comfortable
like we've ran this experiment before
man well i mean they were forced to do
it
because they have to yeah but i mean i
don't know what the numbers are now but
it seems to be like you know
for certain industries it seems to be
okay i mean i think that like some
people yeah yeah i mean i think for like
uh in holly this is
talk hollywood you know it's like a
writer's rooms you know so then you got
you know you could live anywhere i mean
i think the benefit of it is like
uh changing like where people live and
how we live like we do we have to be in
cities
could it be like maybe now i can live in
like even further out than calabasas if
you live in like van nuys
that's not even that far i'm that's
close i'm talking about further
even further out yeah even further than
that like maybe you want to live in
oxnard maybe you want to live further in
a bar
maybe you want to be like a country sort
of feeling and be like
or even like hey i want to i want to
live in wyoming
you know maybe i got a place in wyoming
but there's something about it like
getting together like face to face like
a lot of that stuff it depends on the
again to your point depends on your your
job yeah but everybody got a [ __ ] at
work they hate
true yeah right everybody got that
everybody's like like i gotta go sit my
mom
retired because of a lady she worked
with
just [ __ ] okay so i'm just saying it's
like yes there is a sort of communal
there's got to be a hybrid way to do
this there has to be there has to be a
hybrid well i know what showtime's doing
because they have that expensive ass
building
there in manhattan what they're doing is
they
they can come in any day in the week but
i think it has to be twice a week or
three times a week
so three times so if you have monday off
then you go in the
office tuesday you have wednesday after
going thursday you know you can try and
dictate your schedule
but you just that's not too bad because
i would love the separation
like where i like i don't want to work
at home
what i mean well that's what when you
have well this no offense to you but
it's because there's a lot of people out
there that got shitty living conditions
you know like so if you're living in
like a one-bedroom apartment yeah you
don't want to work at home because you
already hate your place as it is
yeah you know but if you have like a
two-three-bedroom place
and you go this is my because everybody
like you have an office you go this is
where i work
true every place that's where i live but
not everybody has it like that but what
to me what it turns it's going to have
to be about um
good management because how do you have
to stay on your people so it's like yeah
you don't you only got to come in two
days
a week but hey i want that report
remember that report i asked you for on
wednesday you better be on it actually
you got to be here on wednesday yeah
if you mean your pajamas yeah yeah yeah
a week do your thing
yeah let me go pick a kid everybody you
got to get your work done yeah
yeah exactly and now i don't want to
hear about your kid either i don't want
to hear about your kid what's sick i
don't want to hear none of that [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about your kid but
like i
have a i have a friend who works in uh
computers like data
analysts and that stuff and he's like
dude i get my work done
for the week in two days oh he's like
but then they would make me come to the
office
wednesday thursday friday i was done
with my work by tuesday dude
so if they would just be like hey bro
you have to get this done this week
i don't care if you get done on monday
friday whatever it is and you know the
rest of these off
he's like i would be more productive and
get it done but now i know like it takes
me
whatever two days to get done i'll
trickle in one day okay when i work and
i had a regular job i was working in the
office
you know what kind of work i was like i
was out of working at a school but i was
like working in the office i was like a
registrar
the administration building yeah
administration office right so
so like
but i remember the principal would be
like ask me for something
and i i remember one time he asked me
for this thing and i was like oh [ __ ]
how about i got to sit down in like 10
minutes
and i said to myself i was just about to
get up and go give it to him and i went
oh no no no he can't get this in ten
minutes cause then this [ __ ]
gonna always stay expected
like two hours and he still was like oh
thank you that was quick i was like okay
hey little punky like yeah man yeah yeah
so i totally get so if you have like
if you're at home then you could be like
i got that done in 10 minutes now i'm
like watching espn
but if mandarin was like yeah whatever
it takes just get this amount of work
done this week then
we're good all right say less man it's
just a different mentality it's like a
different psychology of like how
like office dynamics change it just
becomes about
like you know then you want to hire
somebody that can take care
to take care of business right away like
you know it's like what you know are you
looking at just qualifications of like
degrees and all that stuff
uh what do they do with how do they work
i mean i guess that's the more black and
white right because yeah
i don't care if he's weird like if he's
coming in the office and he's just a
weird dude you know like the but he
kicks
at work yeah he's great but now you
don't have to look at him or deal with
them dude there's no more sexual
harassment
well you know no one harassing a girl
well they're still [ __ ]
yeah yes they do really online yeah
dude the camera kind of falls down and
they're just like
oh whoa oh is that my dick i'm sorry i
thought that was painless
no it's just like on the bottom of the
screen just kind of like this is waving
and he keeps going sorry about that all
right i get hyped for friday
yeah that's exactly how people would be
i mean it's like it's not gonna be as
bad you know what i'm saying
well i mean maybe but i don't know like
for a guy
like is there still this idea that like
if i'm gonna be on a zoom
i need to dress up at least the top half
yeah party on the bottom
but what about that i don't know anymore
now because what was that is there
wasn't there a correlation about looking
your best you get you're working your
best
yep so i mean i don't know is that going
to go away yeah that's that's right
you look good play good man yeah yeah i
would expect it too like if i
if i owned a business like a straight up
business nine to five
and we're doing zooms and every day
larry's and his jammies
show a little pride but you know linda's
got her rollers and
a baby like this like i was looking at
the files
and i was like let's put your baby down
yeah baby in the crib what you're doing
you know
another problem is my boy he has three
kids and he's a he's a big wig i won't
say where he's a big wig and he's like
the problem is working at home is the
line gets blurred like my kids don't
give up
right right right right right so i'll be
like in the middle of the call can i
come in dad
he's like damn dude yeah my money guy
is like that our accountant guy you know
he's like uh
he's he's got a four-year-old and she
they four-year-olds are on their
schedule yeah yeah you know what i mean
you know what i mean so like when you're
he's in his office she's like what are
you doing
it's playtime if you're home it's play
time yeah so you have to like i guess
you have to like
sneak out the door buy honey and then
you just like sneak in the room or
something i don't know
i mean i figured out some creative kids
don't care i was on a call the other day
important call my kid thought his
feeling kept going fart i'm like bro
you just gotta tone it down for dad for
10 minutes fart i'm like
dude damn he couldn't even give you 10
minutes
yeah what's 10 minutes but once once
they know they get into you right
they're smart man yeah i'm getting to
you
yeah they just want a response